nouvelle édition du 7 8 politique dédiée
aux municipales 2020 aujourd'hui je
reçois nicolas dainville bonjour ce
plateau tête de liste une nouvelle
dynamique pour la verrière
vous êtes déjà élue dans l'opposition
depuis 2000 14 également élu mais dans
la majorité cette fois ci au conseil
départemental des yvelines vous
appartenez républicain mais votre liste
sera plutôt divers droite voire sans
étiquette sans étiquette est déclaré
comme tel
donc c'est à dire que sur cette liste
elle ce sera une liste ouverte toutes
les sensibilités vont être présentés
qu'en est il aujourd'hui exactement
moyenne formule qui me plaît
particulièrement c'est les idéologies
divise les compétences rassemble et dans
notre équipe ce sera une équipe de
bosseur ce serait une équipe de femmes
et d'hommes de bonne volonté qui ont
envie d'apporter quelque chose de
positif pour la verrière
quelles que soient leurs opinions leurs
sensibilités on représentera tous nos
quartiers le bois de l'étang orly par le
village et on représentera tous les âges
voilà on est l'équipe pour la verrière
et une liste d'union de rassemblement
d'intérêt communal
ça veut dire que vous aurez une liste
sans investiture ou avec des soutiens
uniquement ou alors une liste sans
investiture et une liste d'intérêt
communal comme je les dis il n'y a pas
de soutien particulier a pas dit la
belle mon église sans étiquette et à la
préfecture on sera déclaré comme tel
parce que pour la verrière
il faut la meilleure équipe possible
sans logique partisane
depuis le scrutin de 2014 vous avez mené
plusieurs consultations pour proposer de
nouveaux projets sur la commune quelles
sont les grandes lignes que vous avez
dégager jusqu'à aujourd'hui
effectivement on a lancé un
questionnaire avant les grandes vacances
avec un nombre important de réponse de
retour qui témoigne d'une vraie attente
on est une ville avec un potentiel
extraordinaire on a une gare on a le
quartier des bécanes qui peut demain
apporté beaucoup de choses positives à
notre commune mais on est une ville qui
aujourd'hui mal entretenu avec beaucoup
de problèmes de sécurité avec des
problèmes d'emploi avec des problèmes de
propreté
toutes ces problématiques là nous ont
été remontés par les habitants je vous
cache pas que
beaucoup d'habitants nous a témoigné un
certain ras-le-bol
une vraie exaspération ils veulent voir
la ville plus vivante une ville plus
verte
il ya un vrai attachement à la verrière
et les verts hyérois aiment leur ville
mais il ya une petite tristesse de voir
cette ville avec un si beau potentiel ne
pas se développer dans la bonne
direction depuis un trop grand nombre
d'années à la population plutôt jeune
sur sept communes de la verrière et
globalement les revenus centre ci est
plutôt faible par rapport au reste du
département la priorité ce sera aussi
l'emploi pour ses plus jeunes la
formation aussi exactement
vous l'avez dit on a un taux de chômage
élevé les autour de 16% c'est quasiment
le double que dans nos départements des
yvelines
on a aujourd'hui une vraie problématique
pour les jeunes il faut ouvrir les
perspectives d'emploi créé des vocations
et donc on veut mettre nous en avant nos
talents nos talents issus de nos
quartiers qui font un métier utile à la
société qu'ils soient boulanger
ingénieurs avocats et on veut mettre en
avant ses talents allait les faire
rencontrer nos jeunes dans nos écoles
pour créer ces vocations c'est très
important que nos jeunes vers hyérois
voix des talents des réussites et qui ça
leur donne envie de se dépasser envie 2e
même réussir il faut qu'on ait des
accompagnements ou cv qu'on transmette
les codes de l'entreprise on a envie de
s'inspirer de ce que fait mustapha
larfaoui la trappe avec son programme
d'école de commerce de travaux now nous
aussi envie de mettre ça en place à la
verrière pour transmettre aux jeunes et
aux moins jeunes les codes de
l'entreprise pour qu'eux aussi puissent
réussir mais il ya moins de 6000
habitants près 6000 habitants sur la
commune de la verrière mais se pose tout
de même des problèmes de sécurité
quelquefois voir aussi de radicalisation
est ce que si vous êtes élu maire vous
aurez emprise pouvoir pour nous
prodiguer la radicalisation le maire n'a
pas ce pouvoir là mais en tout cas agir
et intervenir alors deux choses
problèmes de sécurité c'est évident il
ya des voitures épaves
il ya de la mécanique sauvage il ya des
problèmes de propreté des problèmes
d'incivilité des problèmes d'agression
et donc il ya une vraie action à mener
faut mobiliser tous les moyens dont le
maire dispose c'est les caméras de
vidéoprotection c'est plus de fermeté
républicaine face à ces incivilités
s'est mobilisé les postes auxquels la
verrière a le droit pour des médiateurs
sociaux
voyez au calme dans nos quartiers
concernant la radicalisation je tiens à
dire que contrairement à la ville de
trappes
on n'a pas eu de départ pour la zone
irako syrienne
il faut qu'on travaille avec toutes les
associations pour travailler dans
l'intérêt ligier dans également
l'ouverture pour qu'on maintienne ce
lien de confiance avec tous les acteurs
donc voilà c'est un point important je
dirais qu'il ya un vrai travail pour
lier plus de liens entre nos quartiers
et pour que nos jeunes et nos moins
jeunes l'intergénération soit aussi plus
fort ça passe par un en tout cas un
travail avec l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines peut-être avec le
département aussi vous siégez déjà
l'agglomération de 50 ans vous vous
travaillez aussi il faut se servir des
ressources des uns et les autres
d'aviation il ya quelque chose à bien
comprendre pour tous nos électeurs c'est
qu'aujourd'hui un maire sol ne peut pas
faire grand chose
il faut vraiment qu'ils s'appuient sur
un réseau aujourd'hui près de 50 % des
décisions de la verrière se prennent au
niveau de l'intercommunalité
je vous mets en précise parce qu'on le
dit pas assez souvent mais que les élus
qui qui vont être désignés lors du
scrutin vont aussi siégé au sein de
l'agglomération sur saint quentin en
yvelines où des communautés de communes
sur le reste des parts exactement de
l'agglomération aux siens exactement et
tous nos projets tous nos projets ils
vont se décider en lien avec nos
partenaires parle par exemple du pont de
la villedieu le pont de la ville dieu
c'est un projet qui est essentiel pour
notre commune avec un pont qui est dans
un état lamentable et le bien de la
dernière révélant cours exactement avec
la zone industrielle de trappes à côté
c'est l'entrée de ville de la verrière
c'est un projet essentiel il faut une
piste cyclable il faut un pont qui soit
digne de ce nom qui soit sûre pour les
automobilistes
c'est un ouvrage qui coûte près de 30
millions d'euros et si on veut y arriver
il faut que l'agglomération soit avec
nous il faut que le département soit
avec nous et que la région soit à nos
côtés donc c'est tous ses partenaires
qu'il faut mobiliser et donc le maire si
on veut être amer efficace et j'aspire à
être amer efficace pour faire des choses
faire bouger ma commune de la verrière
il faut qu'on s'appuie sur ce réseau
c'est essentiel il ya des points à
important là ce sont vos axes
prioritaires mais il ya des dossiers
très importants qui arrivent pour cette
ville de la verrière notamment en terme
de renouvellement urbain de construction
on pourrait parler de ce quartier du
bois de l'étang justement il avait été
question pendant attendent déconstruire
pour
construire les habitants en tout cas une
partie d'entre eux ont exprimé leur
mécontentement ils ne sont pas ils ne
sont pas pour qu'ils aient déjà votre
point de vue sur cette question là et
puis ensuite comment accélérer ce
dossier parce que pour l'instant l'anru
qui se charge de cette rénovation
elle n'a pas été saisie par le préfet
puisque c'est la procédure car
aujourd'hui juge le dossier pas assez
solide écoutez c'est un projet
effectivement qui avait été poussé en
catimini au lendemain des élections
municipales de 2014 que les habitants
ont découvert beaucoup sont tombés des
nues
c'est un projet qui a braqué une partie
de la population et donc quand on a une
telle population braquer on peut pas
faire quelque chose de positif il faut
un minimum d'adhésion il faut que les
habitants s'y retrouve
ils ont compris qu'ils avaient des
problématiques de relogement ils ont
compris que les intentions affichées il
retrouvait pas donc voilà nous on a
proposé un projet alternatif il faut
qu'on fasse quelque chose pour ce
quartier du bois de l'étang peut pas le
laisser dans l'état actuel il ya des
choses qui nous semblent importantes on
parle du mur anti bruit parce que cette
problématique du bruit elles
empoisonnent la vie des habitants il ya
le problème du stationnement ya la
problématique des antennes relais des
lignes à haute tension qui sont entre
frictions d'une partie des immeubles de
destruction massive
c'est par un soldat pour un projet
alternatif où les habitants puissent s'y
retrouver et kiên adhésion du maximum
d'habitants
ensuite il faut être très clair demain
je sais pas à quelle sauce on sera mangé
le préfet a l'air d'être très déterminés
sur ce projet il ya une chose que je
sais c'est qu'on sera plus fort quand on
a les partenaires avec nous pour
défendre le meilleur projet des aides
pour les habitants donc moi ce que je
dis c'est qu'il faut mieux
un maire qui travaillent main dans la
main avec l'agglomération main dans la
main avec le département pour défendre
le meilleur projet pour les habitants
donc voilà ça sera nous notre ambition
le meilleur projet le projet le plus
ambitieux pour les habitants on arrive
bientôt à la fin de cet entretien un mot
sur la participation dans cette ville de
la verrière quel que soit le scrutin la
participation est plutôt faible autour
de 54 % pour les dernières municipales
en 2014
une fois de plus on pose souvent la
question mais comment amener les
électeurs aux urnes
bon parlons des vrais sujets et après
matic de santé on a zéro médecin pour
6000 habitants quand on prend des
propositions concrètes quand on
s'inspire de ce qui se passe dans nos
communes voisines avec des maisons de
santé avec un partenariat avec la mgm
ça parle aux habitants quand on parle de
médiateurs de vidéoprotection de fermeté
face aux incivilités ça parle aux
habitants il y en a beaucoup dans nos
réunions publiques quand on parle de
notre projet pour la réussite de chaque
enfant avec des cours de programmation
informatique avec les outils les plus
innovants pour vraiment mettre en place
une égalité des chances dans nos écoles
et crée la réussite auquel chaque vers
hyérois petit varois a le droit je vous
promets que ça parle aux habitants on a
des réunions publiques avec un grand
nombre de citoyens il faut qu'il
participe
il faut qu'on fasse bouger des choses et
qu'on propose des choses concrètes au
delà des partis politiques pour la
verrière et pour les verts y est roi
merci nicolas dainville prochain rendez
vous pour vous ce sera le 12 décembre
on invite karl olive qui le maire de
poissy dans l'idée de s'inspirer des
bonnes pratiques au delà des partis
politiques et des bonnes idées à gauche
à droite l'idée c'est de s'en inspirer
et de faire des choses positives pour
notre ville merci encore une fois
candidat à la verrière je rappelle aussi
que sur cette commune sont candidats la
maire sortante nelly dû tuer également
jean yves les issues de cette majorité
et qui a pris ses distances ces derniers
mois qui lui aussi a donc déclaré sa
candidature merci à vous le 7 8
politique se poursuit cette édition se
poursuit direction versailles où la
pression monte après auprès des
instances de la république en marche sur
l'attribution d'une investiture le
comité local en marche et le député de
la circonscription didier baichère
souhaitent présenter une liste mais il
se pourrait que le maire sortant le soin
préféré même si ce dernier annonce et ne
faire aucune demande en ce sens ainsi le
comité local vient de tenir une première
réunion officielle autour d'anne france
simon vous la voyez elle élabore déjà
son programme on écoute didier baichère
député arm qui pourrait d'ailleurs
figurer sur cette liste
simon c c'est le profil très classique
d'un grand marché qu'elle vient de la
société civile guen cinquantaine
d'années qui vit depuis plus de 25 ans à
dark side
elle a fédéré autour d'elle toute une
équipe d'une vingtaine de personnes dont
le profil jeunes ou moins jeunes
viennent quasiment tous delà de la
société civile et n'a aucun passé en
matière politique mais par contre ils
vivent la ville les y invite depuis des
années ils sont soit étudiant soit soit
par an soit y travaillent sont
commerçants ils ont envie que la ville
de versailles
changes ton à quatre grands axes sur
lequel on va travailler qui vont de la
transition écologique à l'emploi en
passant par la culture et bien sûr de
deux piliers qui nous semble très
important que sont la famille là et la
sécurité à maurepas à la campagne
commence véritablement avec les
premières déclarations de candidature
après le conseiller municipal
d'opposition ancien membre de la
majorité en avant 2014 michel chapa
c'est au tour d'ismail havane de se
lancer encarté au parti socialiste en
retrait depuis plusieurs mois il mènera
une liste de sensibilité de gauche mais
qui siège actuellement dans l'opposition
et qui fut conseiller départemental
reportage marylène yapi chine le groupe
d'opposition de gauche mord pas
dynamique et solidaire et ces deux élus
municipaux lancent leur campagne pour
les élections de 2020 avec une liste du
même nom quatre grands axes de travail
transition écologique démocratie
pluralisme et justice sociale
pas d'étiquette rassemblement avant tout
citoyen et participatif tête de liste
l'ingénieur et entrepreneurs ismaila
vannes nous avons créé ce groupe en 2014
avec déjà de l'intitulé citoyens alors
ce n'est pas un effet de mode en tout
cas en ce qui nous concerne nous tout
simplement l'évolution naturelle d'un
mouvement qui a été engagé il y à déjà 5
ans
le programme est en cours de réalisation
la liste présentera son projet complet
lors de ses traditionnels voeux avant
d'entamer une tournée des quartiers avec
des réunions thématiques en février à
maurepas on est moins de familles là on
est 19600 donc on peut que créer une
bonne dynamique
donc il ya le centre commercial qu'il
faut redynamiser la plein de choses il
ya plein de challenge et ça ça me
convient beaucoup couloir toujours
donner la parole aux citoyens et puis
faire en sorte qu'une municipalité
fonctionne de façon plus démocratique
c'est toujours un bon objectif après
faut le tenir c'est pas facile
en 2014 la liste avait remporté 13
reculent 33% des voix au second tour
en refusant de s'allier à celle menée
par michel chappe à la ville avait
basculé à droite après 25 ans de
majorité divers gauche
nous passons à présent à l'agenda à une
date à vous communiquer à trappes ali
rabais maire adjoint qui mènera la
campagne cette fois ci en tête de liste
au maire sortant guy malandain donne
rendez vous aux habitants la maison des
familles le 12 décembre 20h il et mènera
un nouvel atelier participatif dans le
cadre de la préparation de son programme
la campagne de ces municipales dans les
yvelines est à suivre au quotidien dans
le journal de la rédaction direct à 18h
et puis l'intégralité de toutes nos
séquences est à retrouver en replay sur
le site internet ville par ville
à bientôt
[Musique]